you uh applied this uh thinking to
universities in particular
um there's a great
yet another great image on the trade-off
between knowledge and conviction and
it's what's commonly actually can maybe
explain to me the difference but you uh
it's often referred to as the Dunning
cougar effect where you uh when you
first learn of a thing you have an
extremely
um high confidence about
self-estimation of how well you
understand that thing you actually say
that donning cougar means something else
so yeah it's everyone I post this
everyone's like Dunning Krueger and it's
a and it's what everyone thinks Dunning
Kruger isn't it Dunning Kruger is a
little different it's it's you have a
diagonal line like this one right which
is the place you are it's the I I call
it like the humility tightrope it's a
humility Sweet Spot it's exactly the
right level of humility based on what
you know if you're below it you're
insecure you actually have too much
humility you don't have enough
confidence because you know more than
you're giving yourself credit for and
when you're above the line you're in the
Arrogant zone right you're you need to
you need a dose of humility right you
think you know more than you do so y'all
want to stay on that tightrope and
Dunning Kruger is basically a straight
line that's just uh has a lower slope so
so you start off you still are you still
are getting more confident as you go
along
but you
start off above that line and as you
learn more you end up below the line
later so but anyway so this wavy thing
this wavy thing is is a different
phenomenon and it's just it's just
related but so this idea so for people
just listening
um there's a child's Hill pretty damn
sure you know a whole lot and feeling
great about it that's in the beginning
and then there's an insecure Canyon you
crash down acknowledging that you don't
know that much and then there's a growth
Mountain grown-up Mount grown-up
Mountain
uh where after you feel ashamed and
embarrassed about not knowing that much
you begin to realize that knowing how
little you know is the first step in
becoming someone who actually knows
stuff and that's the uh the grown-up mom
and you climb and climb and climb uh
you're saying that in universities we're
pinning people
at the top of the child's Hill so so for
me this is a very you know I think of
myself with this because I went to
college like a lot of 18 year olds and I
was very cocky I just thought I knew it
I know and um when it came to politics I
was like bright blue just because I grew
up in a bright blue suburb and I wasn't
thinking that hard about it and I
thought that you know
um and what I did when I went to college
is met a lot of smart conservatives and
a lot of smart progressives
um but I've met a lot of people who
weren't just going down a checklist and
they knew stuff
and when I and suddenly I realized that
like a lot of these views I have are not
based on knowledge
they're based on other people's
conviction everyone else thinks that's
true now I think it's well you know I'm
I'm actually like
I'm I'm transferring someone else's
conviction to me and who knows why they
have conviction they might have
conviction because they're transferring
from someone else and I'm a smart dude I
thought why why am I
why am I like giving away my own
independent you know learning
yeah abilities here and just adopting
other views so anyway it was this
humbling experience it wasn't just about
politics by the way it was that I had
strong views about a lot of stuff and I
just I got lucky not or not lucky I
sought out
you know the kind of people I sought out
were the type that loved to disagree and
they were man they knew stuff
and so you're quickly and you know in in
again ideal lab culture it was an idea
lab and also I also went to I started
getting in the habit I Started Loving
listening to people who disagreed to me
because it was so exhilarating listening
to a Smart part when I thought there was
no no Credence to this other argument
right the the the the this side of this
debate is obviously wrong I wanted to
see an Intelligence Squared on that
debate I wanted to go see I actually got
into Intelligence Squared in college I
wanted to see a smart person who
disagrees with me talking became so
fascinating to me right it was the most
interesting thing that was a new thing I
didn't think I liked that and so what
did that do that that shoved me down the
humble tumble here number three it
shoved me down where I started to and
then I and then I went the other way
where I realized that I had been a lot
of my identity had been based on this
faux feeling of knowledge this idea that
I thought I knew everything now that I
don't have that I was like I felt really
like dumb and I felt really almost like
embarrassed of what I knew and so that's
where I call this insecure Canyon I
think it's sometimes when you're so used
to thinking you know everything and then
you realize you don't it's like it's and
and then you start to realize that
actually really awesome thinkers they
resp if they they don't judge me for
this they totally respect if I say I
don't know anything about this they say
oh cool you should read this and this
and this they don't say you don't know
anything they don't say that right and
so
and not that I'm by the way this is not
to say I'm now on grown-up mountain and
you should all join me I am often find
myself drifting up with like a helium
balloon oh I think I read about the new
thing and suddenly I think I have I
think I I you know I read three things
about you know a new AI thing and I'm
like I'll go do a talk on this I'm like
no I won't I don't I I just I'm gonna
just be spouting out the opinion of the
person I just read so I have to remind
myself but it's useful now what the
reason my problem with colleges today
is that it's I was a graduated in 2004.
this is a recent change is that
all of those speakers I went who
disagreed with me a lot of them were
conservative
so many of those speakers would not be
allowed on campuses today and so many of
the discussions I had room big groups or
classrooms and this is still you know
this was a liberal campus
so many of those disagreements
um uh they're not happening today and
you I've interviewed a ton of college
students it's chilly it is you know
people keep to themselves so what's
happening is not only are people losing
that push-off child's Hill which was so
valuable to me so valuable to me as a
thinker it kind of started my life as a
better thinker they're losing that but
actually what college a lot of the
college classes and the vibe in colleges
a lot of what is now saying that there
is one right set of views and it's this
kind of you know woke ideology
um and it's right and anyone who
disagrees with it is bad and anyone and
and don't speak up you know unless
you're gonna agree with it it's teaching
people that child's Hills that you know
it's nailing people's feet to child's
Hill it's teaching people that these are
right this user right and like you don't
have any you nothing to you should feel
a complete conviction about them yeah
how do we fix it
is is it part of the administration is
it part of the culture is it part of the
uh is it part like actually instilling
in the individual like 18 year olds the
idea that this is
the beautiful way to live is to embrace
the disagreement and the growth from
that it's awareness and courage it's the
same thing so first of all just get when
awareness is people need to see
what's happening here that kids are
getting losing the they're not going to
college and becoming better tougher more
robust thinkers yeah
they're actually going to college and
becoming zealots they're getting taught
to be zealots and they at in the website
still advertises you know wide variety
of I've you know the website is a bait
and switch you listen to all the
universities yeah it's a bait and switch
it's it's still saying here you're
coming here for a wide intellectual
basically they're advertising this is an
idea lab and you get there and it's like
actually it's an echo chamber that
you're paying money for so if people
realize that they start to get mad
hopefully
and then courage I mean starts you know
yes Brave students there's been some
very brave students who have started you
know big think clubs and stuff like that
where it's like we're gonna have you
know present both sides of a debate here
and that that takes courage but also
um courage and Leadership
um like the the it's it's like if you
look at these colleges it's specifically
the leaders
who show strength
who get the best results
remember the cultural is soft so if a
leader of one of these places says you
know the the college presidents who have
shown some strength
um they actually don't get as much
trouble it's the ones who Pander the
ones who
um
uh in that you know in that moment of
truth they they they shrink away then
they get a lot more trouble the mob
smells blood